but these are questions that are
polished you need to be thinking about
need to be listening to researchers and
trying to work out how do we try to
correct that how do we make this country
a fairer place how do we make it
environmentally safer how do we look
after our natural habitats how do we
become more tolerant how do we encourage
people who look different behave
differently want to worship in a
different way how do we get all sides to
sit around the table and work out how to
pull together and you know there is a
price that you pay if you start to get
that wrong I'm joined by professor of
global history Oxford and director at
the Oxford Centre for Byzantine research
Peter Frank open Peter welcome the show
hi there
very good to have you here I am holding
a copy of the New Silk Roads many of the
listeners will be familiar with your
first book Sunday Times bestseller and
we got a new one now talking to all
things China and Asia and stuff in a
area of the world that we never really
know much about well I'm interested in
in all parts of history I'm interested
in looking as far and wide as possible
but when I was when I was a young boy at
school I I got paid the same stuff year
after year after year I got I got told
about Henry the eighth and his wives and
about the First World War and the
awfulness in the trenches and about how
bad Hitler was and all of that is
important that we learn about but I
never learned about anything else apart
from that I never heard the word Ottoman
Empire or Byzantines I heard a little
bit about about Russia were not a great
deal about the Russian Revolution but I
couldn't understand why I'm older the
nucleus I couldn't understand why people
were trying to point nuclear weapons at
us
we had drills once a month of my school
on a Friday at 2 o'clock to hide under
our desks and you know I watch the news
growing up and I heard about the
Cambodian but you know about the war and
genocide in Cambodia about China
changing and then gentleman square when
I was 18 and I was very interested about
why was it that these parts of the world
like as you just said we never spent any
time talking about and I guess there are
two different questions two different
reasons for the subjects I'm interested
in is first well what what is
interesting in these countries you know
what what did happen that was important
and interesting
where are the stories that are important
interesting for people my age or younger
than me older than me in other countries
but also how we managed to write our own
history about current affairs to where
the only thing that matters is ourselves
and you know today we're talking on a
day where we had lots of dramatic
developments about our political system
in Britain about prorogation this sort
of very unusual word about Parliament
being pushed to one side and Pross I
understand that really matters what
happens in Britain and how we get our
relationship with Europe right but you
know for 99 percent of the world's
population it really doesn't matter you
know if you're in downtown Shanghai
tonight or in Mumbai or in Cape Town or
in Sao Paulo or Mexico City or in Lagos
you know the irrelevance of what a bunch
of men are women doing in Parliament in
London it's important to remind
ourselves of that because we are living
in a world that's changing very fast and
I sometimes think that we have this very
Imperial way of looking at our own
importance I suppose it's fair to say
any country you look at yourselves first
you know of course you study your own
heroes your history your own problems
about politics and their economy and so
on but in that big picture you know
hundred years ago it matters a lot to
the rest of the world you know call to
the world's population in 1914 owned
their allegiance or notional allegiance
I should say to the King of England and
that world unless I missed something
it really has gone you know we've got
great footballers we've got lots of
stuff in this country that we should be
proud of our business our museums our
scholarship and so on but you know it's
that age where men and women in London
shape the world it's over and in a way
today having been out on the road and
driving be in the car and listen to
radio hour after hour after hour the
only thing that's been spoken about has
been about about Breck sitting about
Westminster politics and I you know I
just think that sometimes you you you
can be so worried about what's going on
your own life that you can forget about
the bigger picture and so my books I
tried to put context into how things
have happened in the past what's going
on the future and trying to signal in
this new book about a little bit more
what's coming what's coming towards us -
yeah it's it's interesting what you say
I wonder how many other countries and
you will be able to share
some light on this um I'm sure how many
countries are living within this filter
bubble where they're so primarily
concerned with their own concerns
because that's the case and how much is
especially a curse bestowed on us in
perhaps the UK and potentially the USA
which has been grandfathered in this
archetype of a time gone by where you're
totally right we were ruling a
significant portion of the world so
therefore we were important so is it is
it worse in the UK than it is else why
do you think I think I think it's fair
to say that everybody has a Rose tinted
spectacles when it comes to look at that
past and everybody you know wants to
think that they're important that's
completely reasonable
you know that's clearly in case the
United States for example a real
challenge where the mindset is about
cold war and about managing a process
and about the end of the belief obvious
and purpley logical reasons to that
America is the world's greatest
democracy their world's most powerful
country and so on and so the way in
which you look at people around you of
course is it makes a difference I
suppose the easiest way to answer the
question is I thought if you put up a
picture of David Beckham or Tom Cruise
in any city in the world everybody would
know who that got they are right pick a
film style pick pick a pop star pick
Taylor Swift you know whoever you want
you know they have worldwide renown
because other people spend a lot of time
looking at us right we have a lot of lot
of tourists coming from all over the
world to London Paris New York and so on
really keen to learn and to learn the
stuff we do well and I guess right now
to learn the stuff we don't do so well
you know it's a very interesting moment
again with the brexit stuff going on
right now to be thinking about how does
that look to other countries how does it
look when the Prime Minister bypasses
Parliament or looks like you're trying
to bypass Parliament to get us away know
that that says something very specific
to countries where dictators or
authoritarianism regard for the
political process so I think that the
truth is is that most other countries
are quite good at looking at maybe not
all other countries but they're quite
good at looking at Britain quite good
looking at France quite good at looking
at United States quite good at looking
at Russia so I think if you asked you
know school-aged kids or university of
tertiary education kids around the world
what they know about Europe they'll be
generally quite clued up whereas Ida
thought you could walk into the highest
performing high number of a stars
possible in any degree course you want
and ask a very basic question about
China
you know who's who's the most important
Chinese emperor not a good one
not bad one not a fat one not a thin one
just name one
most people cards right who's the most
important African musicians it's not
just history and that boring stuff
people like me like doing in libraries
and traveling around you know who are
the big film stars in India or in
Nigeria in the film which is growing at
huge rate and if I employs a lot of
people in the UK in terms of editing in
terms of distribution to the rest of it
you know we are very disengaged because
we expect people come to us and I
suppose there are interesting points in
history where where that is the sort of
symptom of imperial decline when you get
lazy that other people come to you you
need to bother learning other people's
languages you don't need to bother
watching anybody else's football league
because it's obvious our football league
is part of everybody else's and the
reason or else is by the way of course
is because we we pay the players more
than anybody else
and as a result that means that the
glory is that much higher that means
they know people can afford to buy
football clubs on the ultra ultra ultra
rich you know you up in new cars for the
time being you so got Mike Ashley you
know the maid has made him it's here
with his with his clothes attribution in
the UK but my team Chelsea from what my
sins you know boxed and a team in the
1780s when I grew up up and down between
the top two teams he knows owned by
Russian oligarch whose money comes from
minerals and oil from Siberia and
elsewhere you know and you know
Manchester City the champions of England
are owned by essentially their ruling
family babbitt Abbey
Paris has you know the best French team
and they're not great the French teams
but you know that seldom are oh by the
ruling family of Qatar you know so this
is a new world where where rich people
are coming from different parts of the
world you know unless the city that won
the league at Iona you know Everton that
the road you know from promoter with an
Iranian bad debate a lot of money with
the news Beck tycoon who used to by the
way own a third of us so you know this
world looks to us brown familiar because
we are sleep you know we don't think
about
how other people are becoming wealthy we
don't think about other systems of
government we assume everybody wants to
be like us we assume therefore that well
we shouldn't we shouldn't really have to
work too hard you know so we'll go away
on holidays different countries you know
no need to learn any other words only to
say please thank you
you know the Brits are pretty good you
know I find any part of the world you go
to you know Southeast Asia up country
layouts you could pay your bottom dollar
when you hear somebody in the breakfast
they're going to be from England for
some way no we haven't got that
traveler spirit in us but by and large
our education system has shut that down
on curiosity shut it down the digital
areas of is a real challenge to draw
about because it streamlines choices so
it's a very long answer a simple
question you know are people better on
it than we are you know I don't want to
over claim other countries you know I
don't want to say the other people are
all getting it right but by and large
other countries are much better at to
try to work out how to deal with other
people who are different and you know
some of that starts with basic things
like language you know our bilingualism
in this country if you don't have a
parent from a different country there's
an almost zero chance that you will
speak another foreign language and you
know look at our friends across the
across the North Sea in Holland the
Netherlands you go down in Sampson and
people will answer you in five or six
seven different languages and that would
seem to me the best preparation doesn't
you gonna get it right but better
preparation to understand that people
don't always look like you do don't
waste think like you dude you've got
you've got to work out to negotiate and
I've learnt you know we're just talking
before we started talking about about
having dinner and who does the cooking
and stuff and you know you learn in
successful friendships and successful
relationships success relationship with
parents families loved ones and so on
that compromise and negotiation is the
key of communications two key to
everything and I think in Britain for
all sorts of reasons
partly we have a very proud past to
think about that that also throws a
shadow over us where we just assumed
that our place in the world is taken for
granted and I think as the world gets
more complicated as the world gets more
dynamic in other corners of the world
that not a law in Europe we have to be
thinking very carefully about how to
prepare the next generations in that
yeah you told you right the fact that
other countries have to bend around the
ink
leaders so to speak globally which are I
guess traditionally ourselves and
obviously America and and those
countries you totally right all of the
people who are listening the British
will know what it feels like to go
somewhere on a holiday and just expect
the other country to speak people love
the Brits I mean there are going to be
hotspots where we don't do ourselves
proud and moments yeah when you know
things go wrong but you know you know
the Brits are famous around the world
having good sense of humor we're famous
for our sense of justice you know we do
try and get political decisions right
you know we haven't really we have a lot
to be a lot to be really proud of but
you know in the world that move on the
move around us with new technologies
with challenges coming towards us you
know it's not surprising that other
countries will say look look at the
composition of the UN Security Council
for example which in theory is the kind
of global government to try to solve big
problems you know is it right that you
have Russia France Britain and China and
no not a single African permanent member
not a single other Asian member like
India or Pakistan no one from the Middle
East you know no one from South America
you know and reflective of population
sizes the fact that we are Britain where
the population 60 million have a seat on
the Security Council that's permanent
you know it's something which we
shouldn't take for granted you know we
should be able to explain why we're good
custodian and why we're good for global
governance but again those kind of
arguments are quite tricky where with
breaks that we're trying to say we can
do things better than our 27 European
neighbors and you know I'm not I'm not
on your podcast to try to lose half of
the or 48 or 52 percent of the audience
but you know we've got to think quite
carefully about are we sure empirically
that we make better decisions than other
people right whether they are European
Union partners or otherwise and there's
a kind of an assumption I think amongst
a lot of the breaks and tears that I
talk to you is that the Britain makes
good decisions on its own and as a
historian I'm not interested in whether
that's right or wrong whether I feel
it's right I'm interested in measuring
it I'm just improving it I'm interested
in trying to assess and look at data to
find out whether that's actually the
case and I think you can draw different
conclusions from trying to assume that
because we're decent people we always do
things right because the last century
you know it's a pretty long list of
shame as well as the glorious top two
that we have to put a little put on the
on the other balance sheet yeah you tell
you right so relating the New Silk Roads
your most recent book to its predecessor
how do these two relate and why did you
write this new one what's the first big
book I wrote which is you know it's
quite a chunky one and lots but notes
explains how I think the history the
world looks from from you know from
across a couple of thousand years or why
it is that always the people's the
commodities like spices like silk
eventually because our oil and gas to
quite recent but you know why it is that
the spine of Asia and the heart of Asia
was always being where empires have been
shaped and formed including the British
Empire that the Persian Empire Alexander
the Great you know the great Greek
general you know he didn't it was
interested in conquering Switzerland and
Germany and Scotland or getting up to
Newcastle new valleys don't have a great
it was all about conquering going
eastwards right I'm so trying to explain
why that's been so important to history
and I my book was published in in 2015
and I spoke to my publishers about you
about a year and half ago and I said
look a lot has happened since then you
know we've had the election of Trump
we've got the brexit debacle you know
hasn't still hasn't been resolved the
rise of new technologies the more the
greater awareness of climate and climate
change it's coming towards us you know
Russia has had a very significant
process post the invasion of Ukraine and
Crimea annexation of Crimea a lot of
these countries are on the move
India Pakistan in the last two years you
know as close to a military
confrontation as they have been for the
last seven or eight decades so I said to
my pollination I'd quite like to write a
new last chapter to bring it up to date
and they said great give us three or
four thousand words which is about 10
pages or something and I say I'm a selca
so I went and sulked for a little bit
and then I said look I'd like to write
something a little bit longer than that
and they said no your book is already
quite long so adding an extra 60 or 70
pages doesn't cut the mustard so I said
that I quite like to write a sort of
short book about it and that's what this
one really is it's kind of final chapter
that
at the last three or four years where
all these trends of confrontation of
China and the United States through
trade was pressure on the European Union
whatever's gonna happen with it
I suspect breaks it's not going to be
the last last chapter by any means and
that that movements in Iran with the
collapse of the Iran nuclear agreement
that these parts the worlds are all on
the move so it's a kind of it's a
breezier read that tries to explain what
it is that's really important today and
breaks it and trump up for sure a part
of that story but again the more
important things as a historian and I
guess a commentator I'm interested in
resources I'm interested in power
understand economic distribution
demographics where are people where
where where if you land from out of
space and you say what really matters
what's in your top ten and you know it's
an awful thing to say to people
listening to this in the UK but you know
Brett's it really isn't one of them a
Trump is a different story the direction
of u.s. foreign policy and economic
policy does shape global affairs and put
you know so that gets a bit of attention
in my book too but this rise this new
changing world where we look in the
developed world you know in Europe and
United States and so on people
decoupling you know the story of the
West as I guess it's a broad world
Canada is a part of that Australia is
part of it the broad world of the West
right now is about putting up walls in
some cases literally you know whether
it's in in Dover count you know stopping
the current disconnect come from Europe
or United States in Mexico it's about
pulling out of things about going it
alone being convinced that we could do
things better and in the parts of what
I'm interested in all the story is about
greater levels of connection it's all
about building roads building railways
collaborating working together having
free trade agreements and you know some
of that looks good on paper and in
reality it's complicated lots of these
countries lots these people's internally
and with their neighbors have very
complicated relationships someone that
can't stand each other some of them have
real military military competition and
arms races between them and so sometimes
that kind of glossy the glossy nice
happy words all sounds one thing and in
fact the reality is much more serious
whereas are pulling out of things Cylons
are in serious and
cases that made so much difference but
trying to balance that all together the
narrative about people's across Asia is
that look that time has come
this is two-thirds of world's population
living between Istanbul and more or less
in Beijing and that's where 85% of the
world's rice has grown 65% of the
world's wheat 80% of the world's oil and
gas resources and and like I said about
4 billion 400 billion people so it would
seem to me if these populations grow
richer will they become poorer or no
some from climate change or they go to
war that's going to have a very dramatic
impact on our lives and actually balance
how trucks can move between Holland and
Netherlands and Belgium doesn't really
matter doesn't move the dial the place
is is that i look at the population wise
resource wise the competition and the
long-term consequences those those are
the things that are shaping the world
not on the future they're shaping the
world of us now it's just we're not
looking at it because it's all about
Boris it's all about Jeremy Corbyn it's
all about tried to blood lat here at
home so you understand this much better
than I do and much better than pretty
much anybody is into this thing's going
to as well over the last few years since
you wrote your last book have you got a
five favorite incidents or particular
situations or areas that you've looked
up any that you think I know this might
be like trying to ask you choose your
favorite children but if there's
particular particular incidents that you
think that you've found particularly
interesting it doesn't have to be Trump
doesn't have to be breaks it you know
what what are the areas that you covered
in this book that was surprising or of
real interest to you I'll tell you what
Chris you know I'm extremely lucky that
I get to travel around a lot and the
first thing you learn to do if you well
the first thing you should learn to do
when you travel is to listen and you
know I don't mind being stuck in the
lift with anybody whether that's a local
farm and whether it's a big wing
politician whether it's you know
someone's unemployed whether it's with a
student
I think it's listening to hear what it
is other people well they think you know
and to work out why they think it that's
I think what what a good analyst does a
good scholar does is that is that you
try not to
judge you tried to leave your own biases
to one side but you tried to look and
listen and you know this is a rolling
story very hard as a historian you know
I suppose you know I feel like I'm a
clay court as a clay court tennis
playing on clay
I tell it like I'm a really good tennis
player which I'm not I understand I
understand when you play on clay court
tennis the ball balance is very slowly
so you you know these very long rallies
right wears on grass at Wimbledon it's
all quick wham bam thank you ma'am
and I think historians are not always
very good I think I find it difficult to
process in real time whether today's
announcement for example about
prorogation of parliament how
significant is that in the great grand
scheme of history because I'm trying to
look backwards and stuff I know has
happened rather than reacting day to day
so I really admired and I've learned my
hugely journalists who are writing about
their opinions in real time because it's
a really tricky skill to have and it's
not easy to get right and it's very easy
worse than that
loyal is it hard to get it right it's
worse because then in three or four
years time looking back on it you could
be told that you're wrong so you know
I've learned not to try to overdramatize
and sort of disguise individual events
but I think that the the traveling I've
done in the last five or six years I
spent a lot of time in all over the
world and it's it's to recognize that
the biggest single shift has been the
discrediting or what practical democracy
looks like and some of that is extremely
unfair and I'm justified and unfounded
but some of that is to do with the
language that Trump uses you know when
you talk about [ __ ] all countries when
you talk about when you've trash talk
are the leaders you know whether it's
Trump talking about Justin Trudeau or
anybody else yeah where you turn on you
and if you turn on your friends to lose
your enemies that sends a very powerful
signal to people listening around the
world that you know you're not decent
cricket playing law who abide by the
rules you make things up as you go along
you know when you bomb countries without
UN Security Council approval or when you
pull out of agreements that the rest of
the global community want that on not
only discredit the democratic traditions
we have here it provides grist to the
mill of people who want to do things
in a different way whose authoritarian
ways and look very different to us so if
I over again over the last few years as
well as seeing I'll model you know it's
very hard to be trying to say you should
be more like us in Britain you know
where half the part of the Parliament
words beat the other half will have a
country words the other half and worst
in the other are idiots regardless of
which side you think it's very hard to
be selling that model and equally
China's very good at this I'm very good
at saying well we offer alternative
right which is you can have economic
growth but you know that we're gonna
have to cut a few corners and we're
gonna have to make things difficult for
you to be free in the way in which you
want and accept and you know that over
the summer
the protests in Hong Kong have shown
that how fragile that can be too but you
know I think that that process of seeing
how resilient authoritarian regimes is
it's something that takes people like me
very much by surprise we always assumed
that as people became richer they'd want
to have a greater participation in
political process and the evidence
doesn't show that's the case China's one
obvious example but the Middle East in
lots of different countries shows that
to Russia likewise where the reins of
the apparatus are in the hands of the
very very few and in some cases you know
some of those authoritarian regimes to
be quite quite good funnily enough
reform in getting rid of corruption
having greater transparency in legal
processes and so I think we are drifting
into this kind of bipolar world where
that there are two wheels spinning in
different speeds you know and and places
like Africa they're very much on the
move in transition are getting a huge
amount of attention from Chinese
businesses from the Chinese state not
exactly in the way which we think often
people think that Chinese are just
trying to extract resources but actually
China has as a much smarter way of
engaging with Africa and of giving aid
and that and private investment into its
businesses across that continent this
world which is changing is going to be
deeply affected by climate in the future
you know I think that that is something
which is very very clear to me that are
that are the sentiment as as we losing
our way and fight each other and
trash-talking and so on other parts the
world are becoming more confident about
saying we're offering something
different
don't quite take it or leave it but you
know we at least can provide stability
and you know I think that that's a real
real challenge getting poor you totally
right as well what you say about the the
growth that is being seen in the East I
remember I think I'm right in quoting
one of the stats from your book is that
Starbucks are opening 2,000 new stores
in China in the next three years which
is the same as one every 15 hours it's
just a lot it's insane it's so when you
think that's that's you know a US
company US company moving out there that
is what they see as the hugely growing
market so what are some of the
surprising statistics that you've
discovered with regards to this growth
over the last few years obviously China
is widely touted as this huge booming
economy at the moment are there any
other places that might surprise people
yeah I think what China's is is a lot of
the story you know so not only do we
have the growth of places like Starbucks
this summer a whole bunch of fashion
houses got into a big trouble
for labeling Taiwan as being an
independent country and fashion houses
like Bazaar Qi and Giovanni and so on
have had to do grovelling apologies to
allow their stores to stay open in China
there have been huge social media
outrage across China and everything come
Panisse had that targeting I've made
that so-called mistake in China's eyes
has had to make a decision which is does
it does it want to engage in politics
what does it want to make money and
they've all they're all important so you
know example in 1990 China's share of
the luxury goods market was 0% you know
the only people who travel from China in
30 years ago or 40 years ago 30 years
ago Tory were state officials who you
know ideally didn't bring back too many
fancy Italian design and goods with them
now already China accounts for a third
of all global luxury goods and the
assumption according to to analysts and
research is that animals going to rise
to food nearly 50 percent
fifteen years right so consumption which
of course means that when Prada Gucci or
Burberry or whatever it is you know and
Edessa designing a kit what colors they
use what logos they use words they
choose what all of that is going to be
shaped by the cheap consumers and that's
the same tourism where the outbound
numbers of Chinese tourists coming to
visit Europe United States they've gone
through they've gone through the roof
so you know but it's not just a China
story in fact so last year Pakistan was
the fastest retail growing market in the
world right and and we were never cross
our mind that might be the case Pakistan
a population of almost 200 million
people lots of lots a young lot some
under 30s very few of them I've got a
great deal of confidence in the state
right now wrongly don't believe in the
banking system where you know you leave
your cash overnight who knows what
happens to it so they spent and they
spent on having fun because why bother
saving up in a state where you think you
know your future is uncertain you know
why not live not live for now right so
an able listen to this between the age I
don't know seventeen and twenty two
knows is that what I'm talking about
when your parents said to you won't save
you cash rather than going on a Friday
nights you think their marriage or worse
you'd say I'll do my best
and maybe a couple of weeks you'll put a
bit of cash away but most the times I
want to live on the nail in there now
it's it's only later where you think I'm
saving up because there's a sequence but
doing that enables and opens other doors
so Pakistan's a big part of that
India's an enormous part of that the
penetration of you know I can clean its
and fridges and freezers in India it's
very very small and as India becomes
wealthier I significantly so you know
top cricketers there now paid thirty
forty million dollars a year with the
world's at world top earners
then then the way in which people live
and spend and so on shifts right across
the board so one of my favorite stats
that I put in my book is about airline
pilot and salaries so airline flights I
mean you know we all know in Europe it's
cheap as chips to to if you're booking
on the right fly it's the right time and
you're having to get 5:00 in the morning
treated like cattle thankthank words and
then and then an extra fifty quid for
your bags to check in but the real
growth and boom in
international air travel is in is across
Asia and it's estimated that that number
is going to spiral upwards it up with it
upwards by by 2030 mainly driven by my
China by India by Indonesia population
200 million again almost by turkey with
a hundred million people in it it is a
huge populations all becoming not just
richer but more curious you know wanting
to travel wanting to taste different
food see how the people live see their
you know to see their sights and so on
and those numbers are mind-boggling you
know they're huge so it's it's a
pan-asian thing you know the the wealth
in South Korea in Malaysia in Thailand
and so on are enormous and they keep
growing because these are a lot of these
dates are well-run they're they are
balanced pretty fair you know you can
fall on the wrong side of people
anywhere and you get to trouble but you
know they have pretty good legal sisters
quite robust they all they all are keen
on being democratic they all recognize
the problem - autocracy they've all got
different experiences that are things
going off the rails from time to time
but you know these are all countries
that have had a had a quasi miraculous
the last 40 50 years you know and it's
not surprising in those countries to
think well this is their time this is
their moment and why would they
jeopardize their relationships with
their neighbors so you know Malaysian
for example they've got a 93 year old
prime minister you know there's a long
complicated story behind how he's come
back to power but you know when you ask
that when he gets asked about China and
should Charlie be allowed to invest into
Malaysia and its infrastructure he says
nope you know I know lots people around
the world are worried about China and
you know it's investments of why it's
doing it and so on but remember the
Europeans came to what's now Malaysia
and two years later we'd become a callin
and we became slaves so you know the
Chinese never did that and maybe maybe
not gonna do that now but you know
rather than telling us to be more like
you maybe you should go and study your
own history and realize why we're have
second thoughts about the nice men
coming for homes and telling to do so in
fact this afternoon there's been a big
press conference where the Indian
formulas would be talking and he was
asked by by General Petraeus who
commanded the American army in Iraq he
was asked look are you whose side you're
gonna come down on you gotta count down
on United States side and
freedom or on China side Tonka see
communism so on and the formulas of
India said not unreasonably I'll tell
you exactly whose side we're gonna come
down or we're going to come down on our
own side right we don't to choose in
your belief make-believe world where
it's either/or we want to do what's
right for us we're not choosing sides
because we don't see it as a choice that
we need to make and those kind of that
kind of attitude those kind of languages
that kind of those kind of choices of
words I think a very interesting for
countries that don't feel they need to
hedge their bets that they're keen in
fact the more money gets invested from
Japan China United States that's such a
the better why I have to pick sides but
we have I think a Cold War mentality
where people are either good or they're
bad
Putin is either good and Russia are
either good or bad Iran good or bad and
then Egypt good or bad you know so and I
think that that's normally tells you
that there's a lack of thought going
into things you know we professors we
could spend hours like I'm doing now
talking about circles but you know you
learned that that things are never quite
so simple then you need to look at it
from every single angle and you know if
you don't get up your backside and go do
that and spend time in those countries
or think about them then there's a
disconnect and here one of our
challenges is we've got a first class
foreign office you know diplomats around
the world who are fantastic brilliant
you know to a man and a woman
it's hugely impressive but they're under
resource that they need more more more
people working there and they ideally
what they what they are reporting back
to London helped shape our policies but
in fact it goes to politicians are too
busy worrying about brexit and how they
should line up behind Boris Johnson see
oh yeah whoever it might be you've
touched on one of the points that I
wanted to delve into here I'm a big fan
of the Joe Rogan podcast as are many of
the people that will be listening and
Joe has a series of guests on the people
who've worked in government
ex-cia staff and people like that and
one of the constant consistent
narratives that's brought up is you
don't need to be worried about Russia
you need to be worried about China
China's the real threat China's the one
that are using aggressive investments
China's the one who have this weird
Social Credit System which I don't have
a clue how it works
China is the one that's got the highest
rates of pollution that are coming out
at the moment China's one that's
creating this Huawei surveillance
potential plan which is fitting the
ability for them to be able to
potentially access networks of security
and all this sort of stuff did you spend
much time looking at these particular
points yeah first question I'd ask next
time you get one either you Joe get all
these people on is to say look I
understand all that but tell me why
they're doing it right all those there
all those things you mentioned I
recognized and they all have better or
worse explanations for them but you know
what what is the aim right and if you
can't if you don't start with that as a
question what does China want what's it
trying to achieve what's it what's the
purpose behind all this stuff if it
really is trying to compromise all of
our networks it's also pool exactly
what's the purpose if you if you can't
answer that then you're not answering
the right questions when you're badging
China as a single state and a single
country overlooking the structures that
sit within the elite and underneath the
elites and the different regions and the
different identities and the differing
whatever and I think it's very hard to
understand a process all about right you
know and I think that with some of these
things I mean I'll take I'll pick a
couple of the ones that the list you
gave me
you know some of those things like the
social credit system I think that with
the right audience and you've got to be
very careful how you say these things
because people can take them the wrong
way but all of us have been on trains
and on buses and stuff where there are
people who are who are who behave in a
bad way right whether it's by littering
or whether it's by loud seeing or vilas
and so on so China does that it says
very simple if you spit on the train if
you don't leave your coffee cup or you
you you listen here and there you
disrespectful then you know you're gonna
lose points and therefore you ought to
go you ever would have your first choice
a holiday right
be able to have cinema tickets on the
night you want to go and I'd have
thought that that to some extent that
would that's all I think we'll get the
right kind of support among politicians
I'm amazed that we haven't had
conversations I'm going to say which
political party I reckon they probably
come from but suggesting that kind of
thing but how you train citizens to be
better citizens how you make people
behave in their role towards the state
well it seems to be quite a natural
thing to be doing and I spend a bit of
time in Sweden in Sweden if you don't
sort your rubbish out into compostables
plastics and metallics and so on you
know you are you become a pariah and you
get into trouble with a local authority
so trying to use this data and it uses
AI and it uses the technology to do it
faster better but they're not the only
people who do things like this right so
that's the person the second one about
about debt and investment and so on what
anybody will tell you is that the best
way to get good terms from your bank for
your mortgage is to go speak to two or
three banks and one of the one of the
open doors that China has is that you
know the United States gives less in
fact you know States contributions into
Africa went down under the Obama
administration from under Bush and
they've gone down under Trump even more
so in all these states it's not that
people are clamoring to get into bed
with Chinese investment and so on but in
many cases that the early show in turn
right so if we want to be part of that
story and we want to invest into it or
all sorts of ways which we could do that
we can loot do trade missions to other
parts of the world you know about for
example is the United States a Business
Forum with Africa this this you coming
up the second half of this year and
there's not a single American politician
at senior level who's in bothering to
turn up whereas the Chinese Africa forum
is led by the Chinese president right so
it signals very clearly that if you want
to have big scale investments the
Chinese are open for business what terms
they learned it on how it's been done
etc all come further down the line but I
think in some of these cases if if other
countries like the United States or
Britain wants to be a counterweight then
there are all sorts of ways in which we
can put our money where our mouth is and
funnily enough Japan is very adept at
doing that in fact Japan's overseas
assets investments are greater than
China's but it does it much more quietly
off the radar many cases is not really
seen or talked about a known amount but
there are many other people who have
skin in the game who are interested in
trying to play the same dual role of
having a stake in what the new world is
going to look like it already looks like
but also getting a good return on your
cash right so where China has made
mistakes of course it's been putting
money into projects that have gone bad
and there been three or four very
high-profile examples all of that but
you know banking is not straightforward
you know you make mistakes I assume that
that we will expect that China will
learn how to lend in a better way
because when you when you mess things up
and you you borrowed billions to build a
port or build railways that don't pay
back at some point you know the [ __ ]
hits the fan
this is view issues my life and the
assumption a lot of the policy wonks it
particularly liza states is that china
really wants to be taking over railways
in East Africa or take care of power
plants in Kyrgyzstan because that's a
strategic asset and I don't see that in
many of these cases they are strategic
assets I don't they're easy to run I
don't think it's self-evident at all
that China wants to control the power
supply for Bishkek in Kyrgyzstan because
what what what actual benefit does that
give what's different is if you can lend
money and you get paid back at a decent
rate and you make your friends at the
same time right so that seems like a
very different kind of game but we have
a very shrill world when we look at
China because there's black and white
that we we know absolutely right to look
at the problems and the difficulties the
challenges the opacity and a way in
which the leadership you know etc etc
etc and protist in Hong Kong getting
persecution of Muslims in Xinjiang etc
but that doesn't mean that one
discredits the whole thing all in one go
you know I think one has to look very
carefully and like I said the very first
question is always what why exactly are
they doing this why do you think that is
is it is it that the particular
philosophy within China at the moment is
this still great leap forward super
growth at any costs is this sort of
where we're at or what do you think the
the current Chinese or
I think it's all about I think some of
it is to do with history and legacy you
know the idea of China looking westwards
is a long part not just from back to
Ming Dynasty but even under communism
and as UN lion and so on the kind of the
idea that Chinese have better local
regional partners seem self-evident
that's part of the kind of narrative
part of it is to do with China's own
long-term needs parts the world like
Central Asia are very rich in minerals
particularly oil and gas but also iron
and steel and iron and zinc and gold and
silver and so on and so forth some of it
is to do with we're trying to work out
what it needs in the future some of its
to do with China displacing the fact
that it's grown a lot internally and is
now shifting from a manufacturing base
to services industry so all those
workers who've built roads and tower
blocks and train stations they could all
be deployed elsewhere and so some of
these contracts help fund Chinese
state-owned businesses and private
businesses so there were opportunities
some of it to do with the fact that
markets like Pakistan and India you know
with with a combined population of more
than one and a half billion people those
are quite attractive markets for the
future too so and then I think that
there's the security angle as well about
you know trying to share a particularly
big border with Afghanistan but you know
it shows it shows a paranoia about what
fundamentalism will look like and is
using a heavy hand to crack a crack a
nut by by these internment camps in
Xinjiang with a million maybe more wee
girls who have been reso called
re-educated so there's a whole
combination of sloughs in that and then
on top of that you have personal
ambitions characteristics and the
provincial governors for example in
Xinjiang stream Li ambitious with an eye
on on a promotion coming up the line if
he can run his province well and like a
pin and so you know I think there's a
whole multiplicity of all of this to you
but what what what what you were what
China watchers will always do is assume
there's a kind of master plan and that
speaks of our own racial ideas about
what we think Chinese people do we take
charge you were very good at maths and
therefore they must have a master plan
and it's sometimes there is a plan and
sometimes it's chaotic
you know said there's a Silk Road that
haiji at the moment there's a silk road
to do with polar icecaps there's a silk
road to do with you know anything you
like you know with with earthquake
detection and that that badge has been
stuck on the front of everything and so
it's easy to assume that because
everything says Silk Road that there is
a kind of a blueprint behind the whole
lot but the core the spine of it I think
is preparing China for what its own
needs are preparing China for its
next-door neighbors I prepared China for
what it thinks the world of the future
will look like both in terms of its
challenges threats but also its
opportunities and you know that doesn't
mean that those calculations are right
it doesn't mean that they're going to
get their projects right doesn't mean
that their calculations they're making
are correct but it's very striking to me
that when you start thinking about what
the long-term needs are you probably
have a better chance of getting some of
the bits right then if you don't know
what's happening after the 14th
September which is exactly where we are
now we've got no idea whether we got
medicine or the other this year
what better still we need to be stocking
up and you know you could spin it the
other way around it go well that's
because we do things properly we listen
we tried to conciliate and then you know
it doesn't take a genius to say well
that doesn't seem to work particularly
well
and so you know I think that that as
these different worlds are forming
what's interesting is that everybody
else has a long term plan you know
Kazakhstan has its 2030 plan Vietnam has
a long term plan Russia has a long term
plan and that the closest we've got to
when President Xi announced the belt and
rose initiative the new swords in 2013
almost he's out at the same time we
announced the HS to train line to
connect London with Manchester so far we
spent six billion quid on it haven't
laid a single meter attract 60 grams
gone on gym memberships would even work
for HS too if you look and in fact they
change they changed after my book six of
my book came back so I think somebody
read it if you look at the northern
powerhouse portal which used to be no
strumpets what's being done for that
normal power so we read about in the
press until recently the most important
development was the opening of the South
front of Leeds trade station and at the
end of last year the big feeling of
celebrating was a series of poster
displays at Manchester Airport
celebrating industrial development
in a revolution of the north so in that
in that bio six-year period that I'm
talking about in this new book you know
the rate of change elsewhere has been
monumental monumental and you know it's
we fiddle when Rome burns partly because
no one says that we need to do any other
way you know we still walk into a
bookshop in there and as books about hit
and I still watch the news and it's the
same sort of thing and the truth is
normally people don't want to read about
other parts of the world and so it was a
Mis complete mystery to me when my first
book came out and it did so well it
caused you know I spent years going to
drinks Bart's dinner parties explaining
the parts the world I work on and no one
gives two hoots whereas now suddenly
everybody does understand that no Turkey
Saudi Arabia Iran the Middle East
Pakistan and India China Southeast Asia
Russia Iran you know etc we need to be
thinking about that and really thinking
about quickly and that very hard to do
it used to talk for a position of their
knowledge you've spoken about the rapid
growth that we've seen over this past
five six year period or so one of the
things that was keen to bring up some of
the costs that have come associated with
that now again perfect avatar for the
layperson of understanding global
politics right here like if it doesn't
your honor on a Facebook post that's
been shared by one of my friends are on
a really high up BBC news article
probably haven't seen it but the stuff
that I see about dangerous rates of
pollution about levels of happiness in
in these sort of countries and again it
is this incredibly imperialist view that
it's like well if they're getting that
right it must be at the everyone must be
hating it or it must be another Great
Leap Forward or it must be there must be
swimming in smog and stuff like that but
did you look into some of the costs that
have been associated with this rapid
growth over the last the answer that one
it really is how long is a piece of
string because when you look at costs
you know you've got social costs you
know rising wealth means in explicitly I
suppose rising inequalities you know as
rich get richer then and the poor don't
move there that's a difficult thing for
any society to to work through
particularly when it's extremely rapid I
you know said that there are costs there
that that has
implication through to provision of
healthcare through education where
things become uneven because people in
wealthier parts of different countries
have different stand as they get
probably some time selling as well right
well probably probably some crime period
places where you get high inequality of
wealth is also places where you
associate high levels of crime I got
something that I'm sure that that sounds
to me like like that that's probably
correct I thought that that may I don't
know about the data behind all of that
because well I guess is quite often
things I think sound about right and
some reason to be not correct but you
know the environmental cost is obviously
enormous the the carbon emissions in
China as you've already said are amongst
the highest in the world what most
developing countries will say from
Brazil huge in the news at the moment
through to countries across Africa and
in Asia it's to say low it's all very
rich for Europe to turn that's about
this when they burn all the coal that
that you know went up in the sky from
the 1800's onwards and that you've all
had your Great Leap Forward to
industrial either build your cities
build your railroads now you always stop
us from doing it so ironically China and
Russia and Turkey are within their
limits that were set by the Paris
Accords whereas the Paris climate
agreements the Donald Trump is pulled
out of here in Britain where we think
you know we're quite sensitive we all
like that Swedish girl who's like talks
about climate we all know it's got a
problem coming towards that it wasn't a
great summer this summer and so on but
as it happens we we're exceeding our own
limits that we separate but we agreed to
accept right we assumed other people
break the rules but those agreements
that were made in Paris other countries
across Asia including China are still as
far as I'm aware that's right I think
I'm correct in saying that please don't
hurt me if I'm sure that keep Russia
certainly an Avianca Floyd it's fine
yeah I think they are within the limits
that were set and in Europe most
countries on so I think we have that
idea that other people bend the rules
that we don't you know because we events
the rules cricket and won the World Cup
so you know I think that those things
are hard
I think there's costs in terms of
urbanization the process of people are
moving to cities in India
and China but also all across Asia puts
huge strain on ecosystems on family life
on gender because tends to be well both
women who moved to the jaw movement
particular kinds of jobs and men other
kinds particularly jobs you know that
creates a change in family dynamics
it's absolutely monumental the scale of
these changes and the costs and I
suppose one of the things one has to out
ways is what's a destination and again
most states that I've visited and most
people I talked to across Asia all say
that they are making the sacrifices the
good of their children you know I've
been to places where you know I was in I
was in example I went to Abu Dhabi with
Polk earlier this year the first time
the Pope has ever been to to the Gulf
region and I met a woman who was working
the Philippines she'd been inside she
been in living in Saudi Arabia she'd
come to the UAE to see the Pope Catholic
in the Philippines she'd been living in
Saudi Arabia for 12 years and there
being home twice and she had three kids
she's in twice for total of 10 days and
12 years and she said look I'm doing
that because what I earn here you know
lowest of the low but more than I'd be
getting back home helps give my kids a
better chance and when you have that
kind of idea that your children are
going to have a better life than you are
then you make different decisions about
education and health care about
investment - if you're sure that they
won't and here in the UK of course the
Financial Times we are in this is the
first generation now of under 25 so
we're gonna have a worse turn and living
than the generation that went before
them and there that is why you start to
see disenfranchised disaffected
particularly youth it's the same story
United States by the way where social
mobility and if you're born in the
bottom 20% of the UK or the u.s. you've
got a statistically miles high much much
higher chance for staying there than if
your ball in the bottom 20% in Sierra
Leone or gay born or Kazakhstan and when
that social mobility
crunch comes you think well what if my
life means that there's no option
there's no future there's no ownership
all that stuff I say on love Island I
just see it's a kind of fantasy then
then then you get radicalized and
religious radicalization is part of that
environmental radical radical Asian
Caribbean that all sorts of different
ways in which in a body radicalization
all those kinds of ways in which which
unhappiness can come through the system
you know it changes how states function
so I'm not going to tell you that that's
you know the way in Britain have a bad
future coming towards us but these are
questions that are polished you need to
be thinking about it need to be
listening to researchers and trying to
work out how do we try to correct that
how do we make this country a fairer
place how do we make it environmentally
safer how do we look after our natural
habitats how do we become more tolerant
how do we encourage people who look
different behave differently what to
worship in a different way how do we get
all sides to sit around the table and
work out how to pull together and you
know there is a price that you pay if
you start to get that wrong and I'm
concerned about how things look in
Europe right now because you know you
can see in Greece during the financial
crisis it was 60 percent of the under
25s didn't have a job you know and those
numbers in Portugal Spain Italy at the
height of the crisis were worth 50 60
percent plus and that's one reason why
again regardless of what listeners views
are about the EU you know 58 percent of
the French population think the EU is
not going to last or unsatisfied with it
you know we're not the only people in
Britain who think that the European
Union is a problem my own personal view
for what it's worth is that there's a
lot of projection we want a
lightning-rod so we want something to
blame so we brain blaming you and the EU
problems not a good enough job in
explaining why it's been good for
everybody but clearly that
dissatisfaction that anger in our
politics that name-calling that
bitterness that inefficiency is a
product of the fact that we all
recognize the life is becoming harder
for us and it's going to become even
harder for our kids I think and I put it
in my book that regardless what you
think about breaks it this is the worst
possible moment with China on the rise
Russia isolated Iran right you know on a
different trajectory potential war
between India Pakistan all these clash
ports and Trump in the White House to
choose now to leave a structure seems to
me very very very irresponsible but you
know I also listen on all sides to try
to work out why why people are angry and
I think that that anger is based on
substance but
I'm not sure that we're necessarily good
the solution is going to make things
better but my guess is it'll make things
worse it's a very complicated situation
I was talking to Andrew Doyle create or
the titania McGrath Twitter account the
other day about this and I was saying
that as someone who is not politically
minded but everything that I do is a
political right everything because never
voted I haven't voted and the main
reason for that is I haven't educated
myself sufficiently for me to feel like
my vote is worthwhile I don't want to
vote just off the top of headlines that
potentially may be wrong but
increasingly
and much more so during the period that
you've been writing this book last five
years or so I've been finding myself
being dragged into political discussions
the things that I do that don't have
anything to do with politics or somehow
becoming politicized I'm not I'm not the
way that I conduct my business literally
my own business that I've run for 13
years it's not to do with my political
stance and my political stance also
isn't something for public consumption
it's just how but yeah I think that
lightning-rod someone to blame that
isn't us everyone likes to guess a
little bit of Gaslight in here in there
and it's a little bit like European
Union Gas Light and so before we
finished up what I wanted to briefly
touch on because it's it's quite topical
at the moment is this situation in
Brazil I just wanted to get you your
take on how that's been received
globally obviously you've got a much
wider perspective than then most people
will do so what what you thought the
preservation of the Amazon is is crucial
for all of us you know I think that
Bolton ro is a populist leader which you
know as many countries have where they
say and do irresponsible things and then
you know while it's all happening cracks
wisecracks about about the French
president's wife you know on Facebook so
it doesn't seem to be taking it
seriously
you know I think that the way in which
the NGO community tries to respond and
tell people OFF probably isn't obviously
helpful you know we've announced that a
package of 20 million dollars which
doesn't pay for an enormous amount I
think we've got to try and think very
carefully I mean I'm supportive
Surgical Survival International which
looks after indigenous peoples rights so
it's not just about the lungs of the
earth as they're called and about the
greenhouse impact it's about the people
who live in these lands and who has been
booted off for search of cash but you
know I think we are arch hypocrites here
in the West that you know if you want to
stop Amazon the Amazon being deforested
and then we should stop let's meet you
know we should stop by things that are
directly implicated into it and you know
if you watch if you watched our course
if you you you know you you start to
think about global supply chains there's
no such thing with all due respect Chris
I think of being apolitical because
everything everything's political you
might you might not want to admit it you
might not want to think about it when
you buy your TV whereas it made or
whether your jeans are Fairtrade or
whether they're made by something that
costs five quid and you think I'm not
gonna ask about how they were made aware
but you know you're gonna guess that
they're made in a different way to be
made for 50 quid up the road although
that doesn't always mean does always
work out higher they sometimes you get
Scouts for your conscience but you know
I think we all have a responsibility and
in our digital world where information
is not always reliable a lot of fake
news but you know it's not hard to find
things out it's about asking those kind
of right questions you know I think
we're all complicit in that destruction
the Airman's and because we want to have
our niceties in life and that starts
with beef but that's not the only thing
- it's about a global capitalist order
which is much better in the alternative
by the way as a student of Soviet Union
you know where the persecution as murder
and oppression are the kind of calling
cards you know I think that we need to
think very hard about what kind of world
is we want and again it's a kind of good
line to end all I suppose my view is
that the kind of challenge we have in
the world at the moment about digital
technologies about about climate can
only be resolved by multilateral and by
organizations where people all have a
chair at the table and when you when you
leave the room and say you're going to
work these out on your own you know I'm
not sure how effective you can be we're
obviously much more useful the UK within
the EU within the g7 within the UN
within all these different formats and
being able to have a kind of common
policy
and at the moment we're the ones who are
being forced to take sides because when
we when we detach from from the EU which
looks to me like it's inevitable
you know we've got we don't have
enormous what we can bring to the party
in terms of leverage apart from our
reputation and historians will tell you
that the reputation it accounts for
something but actually it's always to do
with cash and if you want to affect
change then you change the way that you
live and how you spend it's going to be
interesting in another five years time
there might be the I'm not sure what it
would be the Silk Road the Silk Roads
might be fine and you might be talking
about a total collapse of the European
Union or god knows what's going to go on
over the next five years here's one one
question to actually finish on do you
think if you would if you were a betting
man do you think that you will have seen
more change in the last five years or
more change in the next five years I
have me back on into five years I will
play well play tape see you Europe
European Union or Europe Britain you
know we're all Brazilians you know we
are you know even people I disagree with
the people disagree with me you know I'm
happy to this is their point of view no
one has locked up when we talk you know
we have a good civic society here you
know we do try and get lots of things
wrong in this country but you know we
get lots and lots a lot of things right
we can beat ourselves up a lot you know
whatever challenge has come towards us
we're gonna be able to make the best of
it
I don't need any doubt about any of that
but you know I generally like I keep
saying generally the more that you
communicate whether you study the more
you're willing to listen the better and
I think that we happen to be in a period
where our politicians here in the United
States are much better at talking and
not very good at listening and you know
as someone who decides in both talking
today you know I'm I'm mainly my
favorite thing is to hear what other
people have to say you know I've learnt
that that sometimes being quiet
listening is the mark of a proper
scholar rather than someone who pipes up
and and give their two cents all the
time
might be a good tip for some of our
politicians to take
Kawai so I'll try and I'll tweet it to
them I'll see if someone someone listens
and takes it on board but Peter
tonight's been absolutely fantastic I
really appreciate your time the New Silk
Roads will be linked in the show notes
below highly recommend that you go and
check it out if anybody wants to find
you online where should they head Peter
uh Twitter is always the place at Peter
Baker pen and I try to reply if I can
no one's ever no one's been please don't
be rude I've got I'm a meek academic
seen in the library so it ought to start
crying in the library and we're fond of
my students know I love engaging with
you but and very happy to try to respond
answer and so on if anybody wants to
treat happy fantastic if you have any
questions that are nice and well worded
and polite and and don't use too many
emojis then fire them over to Peter
that's a twitter is to it'll be linked
in the show notes below as well thank
you so much for your time enjoy your
your color here off to cook a souffle
and I hope you get it right Chris
[Music]
you